tenir ses chances de vous tous je vous
fais quoi ca conseil de classe en amont
contiennent ohlala maman il a lâché la
rampe
j'adore il est insolent et verdict off
c'est un coureur de fond il a gagné la
ferme et leur meilleure saison k-way a
confiance par contre c'est à dire à ton
problème c'est que tu prends énormément
la confiance on me supporter je vais te
dire non s'est passé ça va être aussi
simple que ça tu sais à tf1 ils ont
trouvé des mots pour se dégager tour
c'est vrai mais ça a été direct
c'était quoi dégage connard tu as envie
de te dire bis repetita il a fallu hors
catégorie on sur dix n'ont vraiment pour
vous c'est le meilleur ah oui mais ça je
me dis depuis toujours là en fait j'ai
voulu rigoler j'ai dit qu'il était nul
fois ci puisque la tranche d'âge à vrai
dire la vérité pour lâcher le meilleur
jeu menaces imprévues
c'est vrai que ça fait la gueule pendant
de ken rées mena sont très bonnes
vérités dans la foi il a dit tu vas voir
je vais te péter la gueule oui en plus
japon il des mots ici très sympathique
et quoi les mots vous avez appris nique
ta mère
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il a complètement ça me plaît parce que
justement ça me correspond pas un genre
de mots mais ça me plaît c'est amusant
bon c'est affreux je suis désolé auprès
des mamans bien sûr il est amer c'est
rigolo face et chérie on obtient tout
public par week end au fait
bah
mais là
voilà là
à
[Applaudissements]
attention attention c'est parti celui je
vais lancer la balle celui qui gagnera
les 50 bâle ii bat nicolas pernikoff ses
partisans voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette élection n'a ni queue ni tête
qu'elles sont proches de bernard montiel
med un fumiste qui vole les émissions
des autres avait mis 0,5 g
pourquoi est ce que c'est bien payé mais
voilà ils volent les émissions des
autres vous le savez ça bah oui je sais
la belle en un mot alors babel c'est un
garçon que vous avez littéralement
dépuceler avant il était bien coiffé
décoiffé pas maintenant vous l'avez un
petit peu celle d'hier et il est parfait
et femmes alors que c'est un [ __ ] mais
je peux vous garantir que moi il n'a
jamais essayé de me sucer quelle belle
émission on adore mais bon cette
résurrection
bravo la direction ça fait quand même
dire qu'ils considéraient qu'il était
mort
[Rires]
vous animez le rock c'est m oui mais il
ya même eu une rumeur comme vous étiez
membre jouer prg que nous perdons deux
fois c'est sûr que c'est vrai que c'est
vrai nom 1120 ne devriez pas encore avec
vous pourquoi je suis si triste
il est en berne à monter vous avez
raison vous avez du goût j'étais au
restaurant avec des potes et j'ai vu
leur horaire qui héberge chez les morts
en faut mais je vais emprunter la
mission comme john eales et festif il
est drôle il est décalé mais aussi drôle
devant derrière
enfin je veux dire aussi drôle vous
parlez est ce que vous parlez de son
slip ou donna sur le plateau que dans
les nominations en même temps qu'il
arrive c'est ça l'unique salut l'écu
salue les plus salués connard donc c'est
toujours très sympa de saluer ces gens
très jeunes et non il est c'est un what
the fuck absolument solaire
moi j'ai mis révélation que ce souffle
obama il s'est révélé cet avis est long
plus drôle ça et versus postpaid way fly
peur de l'émission g8 vous êtes cela dit
il faut je vous dis je les ai tous
menacés
cet incident est un mot de travers est
extrêmement drôle
la note que vous ont mis les télescopes
s'agit d'ailleurs que qu'important aulas
[Applaudissements]
beauport et montiel ça prouve qu'ils me
connaissent pas et non mais ça prouve
que les gens couverts non ça veut dire
qu'il va me demander une augmentation
l'année prochaine exactement ce qui veut
dire bienvenue vous connaissez le
cheminement le public nhs m
ils demandent une augmentation et on le
revoit plus
[Rires]